Thank you. and it's
great to be here.
So thanks for attending and
participating. Yeah.
We're gonna dive in,
pretty quickly,
but I'd say at a pretty deep
level as to what data center
security and, in particular,
in a semantic graph model,
would look like.
In fact, what we
will do let me
make sure I can
advance my slides.
Here we go.
we'll first sort
of define what
we mean by data
centric security.
We'll talk about, why
this is important.
So the what and
the why and then how.
and of course, we'll
use Flurry since,
it's one I'm
familiar with, but,
Flurry is
a implementation model
of enforcing that data
centric security.
so first with
the, what is it?
What are we talking about?
So this is a term
I really enjoy,
this, data defending itself.
And ultimately,
we think that this is what we
are gonna need
around a significant
part of data management
as a whole,
especially as we
start to connect
data more and more,
connect it,
not only within our four walls
of our organization,
but outside our four walls.
And so data
defending us itself
means at least three things in
our vernacular.
One is knowing that you can
trust the data.
And, you know,
as we see more and much more
machine to machine interaction
around data, effectively,
the machines need, you know,
the same thing
us humans need.
when we're browsing the web,
we get the little lock icon
letting us know that the data
is secure and can be trusted
from where it came from.
that concept hasn't
really existed
or needed to be pushed forward
in the data world
because we've
never really had a truly
interconnected
data ecosystem.
But I think we can draw a lot
of parallels to the world wide
web that we as humans need and
the tools we need around them
to the data web
that ultimately
is where we're going.
So, cryptography, obviously,
and and we'll talk
about, you know,
how that can be accomplished.
But, AI, you know,
machine learning,
machines that are
consuming this
data directly
need to know that
the data they're
they're making
decisions around,
can be trusted.
secondly, that
you can reproduce
the data.
So especially if
we, arrive in a,
what I would say a multiple
observer world where multiple
parties are interacting with,
a single set of data,
trying to coordinate
or collaborate
around a single
source of truth.
They can't do
that in a typical
database model.
A typical database model is
extraordinary historically,
it was designed this
way for reasons,
but it's extraordinarily good
at destroying data.
So, when you update a piece of
information,
you're effectively
throwing out the old
information.
It might exist in
a log for some
period of time,
but the old data is gone.
If we're having
multiple parties
coordinating and
making decisions
around data,
the first thing we
really need is a common frame
of reference. I often draw
parallels to this
with software
source control.
It was
extraordinarily difficult
before we had things like Git
source control for multiple
developers to build code,
because there was no common
frame of reference.
They're constantly stomping on
top of each other.
There was no central
truth to the world,
no reproducible truth.
Data needs that
identical model,
especially when
we're collaborating
around data, again,
not only internally,
but possibly externally,
creating these data ecosystems
with other parties.
So the reproducibility of data
is gonna become very,
very critical.
And, you know, the thing that
we reference here is this idea
of time travel.
Being able to issue a query,
not only for the current
state of data,
but every historical moment of
data that existed.
And again, sitting
on that first
foundation,
knowing that we can
trust the data that
we're getting,
that it hasn't been
tampered with.
And lastly,
data defending
itself means that
it is impossible to circumvent
the security that's
been defined,
the business rules,
whatever they are,
around who can update data and
what the shape
of data needs to
look like. So, you know,
when we think
about, semantic,
standards, we
think about things
like OWL or Shackle
giving some
degree of definition
around how
data needs to look
for it to be valid.
So we need to be able to take
this a bit further,
and we need to
be able to layer
permissioning on top of it.
So not just data shape
is being valid,
but who can change data,
and importantly,
who can see data.
So this would be
the last layer
of what we mean
by data centric
security. So why, why
is this important?
And what we see
is for businesses
to really be competitive,
they are gonna
have to be agile
and get value out of
the data they have.
I mean, I think, you know,
a lot of organizations today
wouldn't necessarily,
consider themselves
data poor,
but they'd probably consider
themselves insights poor or
knowledge poor.
So they have a lot of data.
It's just sitting there.
It's locked away.
It's very difficult
to leverage.
And that's really a symptom of
how we have been building
applications for
the last forty years.
So we have been
developing things
in a very application
centric model,
where the data we
have is really
subservient to
the application.
And as we've needed to expose
that data in other ways,
we develop what I
consider workarounds.
I consider these flaws of our
current data model,
which are APIs.
I don't think APIs should need
to exist to get
access to data.
but what they are is a very
narrow pipe into
that data that's
defined and then imposes costs
not only on the individuals
having to develop the APIs,
perhaps your own
organization,
but it imposes a huge cost on
the consumers of that data.
Because now all they all have
to write custom code
to your custom API,
and then importantly maintain
that over time.
And oftentimes,
it's the maintenance of these
APIs that also
get us in trouble
that introduce
security breaches.
Or we have the other
workaround,
which is I need
to aggregate or
look at this data
across repositories.
I have no good way
of doing that,
so I turn to data
lights or data
warehouses. So I think most of
the people here are probably
familiar with and
fans of semantic
web sort of technology.
But what it allows us to do is
it gives us a foundation
to move into,
instead of an application
centric world,
into a data centric world.
But this then brings this
additional set of
problems around
trust of data, guaranteeing
integrity of data.
Because what it means is that
instead of just
a single observer,
single pipe into these data
repositories
where everything's
controlled, now we
have an ecosystem
of applications,
which gives us
tremendous leverage.
It gives us a lot
of flexibility
around data.
but it also means that our
previous methods of trying to
secure data in the application
tier start to fall
apart because
there is no such
thing as a single
application with
being the only
thing that has access
to data anymore.
It's multiple applications,
but the data is more reusable
and can be leveraged.
So we need to start
thinking about,
embedding security
into the data
tier to make this
world possible
and start connecting
these data sources.
So that's why we think this is
important. So I'll tackle some
of the things we talked about
with some examples of some,
technologies that address some
of these concerns.
So the first thing
that I mentioned,
we think data centric security
means is that you have to be
able to trust the data.
You have to know that the data
has integrity, and this has to
be done in a way
that a machine
can even trust
the integrity of data.
There's really
exciting standard
here that is,
emerging W3C standard around
verifiable credentials.
I'm gonna extend
how you typically
see it, but I'm gonna
use the typical
use cases here for those not
familiar with it
and and how it
works and how it
guarantees data
integrity. In fact,
one of the things
we talk about
these credentials is that it's
like data containers.
We we talk a lot about, like,
Docker and and
computing containers
now a day, currently
in our IT world.
And we think that,
these same principles
can apply to data.
And verifiable credentials is
really the the preeminent,
standard that's
coming around this.
So verifiable credentials is
under the W3C,
the same, you know,
standards body
holding the other
semantic web, standards.
And it's actually
based on even
though a lot of people who are
using it don't
necessarily know
it's based on semantic
web technologies,
it's sitting
entirely on top of
semantic web technologies.
So what is
a verifiable credential
and what does it
matter to data
centric security?
How is this going
to solve some
of these problems that we've
talked about?
the classic example in an area
where we're spending a lot of
time on because there's a lot
of momentum is
the university system.
anything that is a important
piece of information
is what you
would call a credential.
We have a lot of physical
credentials today that would
include your
driver's license,
your passport,
and as it relates
to a university,
it would be your degree.
But of course,
it's very difficult
to validate some of
these mechanisms.
And of course,
they're not digital,
they're mostly physical,
because they're
very important.
So verifiable credentials is
designed to do this.
What it allows,
to happen is that
an issuer can
create a digital, credential.
In this case, it's
a university example.
We're creating
a digital degree,
for out of a university.
And a holder, in this
case the student,
gets that degree.
So blockchain often comes into
this conversation.
Flurry spends a lot
of time, in fact,
its ledger is based
on blockchain
technology, but
it isn't actually
required to make
all this work.
So there's some
optionality to it.
But the benefit
of a credential
is that the data does not need
to be published in a public
manner at all. So,
privacy around
the data is always,
integral to this.
And in fact, in
the coming years,
there's already
examples coming out.
I'm sure Android,
I'm sure iOS will probably be
shipping out of
the box with a out
of the box,
application for holding your
credentials in a wallet.
So in iOS, iPhone,
you already have a wallet for
your credit cards,
you will have
a wallet for these
credentials, which will hold
things like your
driver's license,
and they'll hold things like
your university degrees,
and potentially lots
of other things.
And one of the benefits
is, as a holder,
you determine who you disclose
the data to.
But whoever you
disclose it to,
in this particular example,
would be an employer
that you're
trying to prove you
have this degree,
can independently verify that
that data has integrity,
that it was in fact issued by
the university,
that it's never been
tampered with.
And they can prove
that without
having to use
something like a third
party background
check provider
in order to validate
information.
It can be directly proven.
So this starts to get into how
we prove identity.
And if we, you know,
just step back real quick to
this world where
we have a these
these data pods that are
interconnected and
multiple parties,
multiple applications might be
transacting data,
identity becomes critical.
Because how do we know we can
trust this person?
We no longer have
a single pathway
into updating data,
which is
the application sitting
in front of it.
There's multiple
pathways to do it.
So, a very complimentary,
but independent standard is
around decentralized
identifiers.
And these often goes
hand in hand with,
verifiable credentials.
Decentralized
identifiers allow
you to register
identities, typically,
public, private,
or asymmetric,
cryptography.
So you can release
a public key
but keep a private
key that you
never disclose.
So it's a much safer mechanism
for securing information or
proving identity than
say a password,
which is what we mostly use.
these identities do need to be
registered somewhere
where both parties,
the verifier and the issuer,
can jointly look them up.
And a blockchain
is a very logical
place to put these,
although they don't have to go
on a blockchain.
I could email it to you.
I could put it up on
our public website.
there's multiple ways of
representing them,
which is inherently
what makes them,
decentralized and referred to
as decentralized identifiers.
So you're starting
to see these
a lot more. You're
gonna see them,
much more frequently,
these strings here
that start with DID,
which stands for decentralized
identifier. So what you do is
you take this
credential and you
wrap it in a digital
signature.
That digital signature allows
the employer to
verify that that
is impossible for anyone else
to have issued
this information
except for the identifier
of the issuer.
So that's the basics
of verifiable
credentials, and that's kinda
how they work. What
do they look like?
so if anyone here is familiar
with JSON LD, which is really
just a way of
representing triples,
representing RDF data,
JSON LD is the main mechanism
to represent a credential.
And what we're able to do,
and this would be a sample
credential for
a bachelor degree,
we're able to
provide a context.
This is effectively,
you know,
in a sparkle world,
like a prefix,
except it's a set of prefixes
that are predefined,
and a payload of data.
And this is a data container.
It is self describing data in
a containerized
package that can
also contain a proof
that enables
us to validate that
this data is valid,
that it's never been
tampered with.
So, if we looked
at, for example,
what this context points to,
this context is, you know,
setting up basically
what you're
probably used to seeing is
prefixes for URIs and bringing
definition to all
the data in here.
So if I wanted to
know what a bachelor
degree, you know,
this degree is of type
bachelor degree.
Well, that may mean a lot of
different things to a lot of
different people.
I can refer to
the context here,
you know, look up,
bachelor degree,
which I don't see
it right now,
but I'm sure it's
in here somewhere.
You all probably see it.
Here's bachelor degree.
And I can see that,
bachelor degree refers to this
formal definition
of, you know,
example dot com slash
bachelor degree.
But you see in here,
some of these definitions are
referring to schema
dot org, etcetera.
So we have now global shared
schemas that I
can containerize
this data. I can share it with
other people. They
have the ability
to then reference,
for example,
schema dot org and understand
what all these terms are that
I put in here with a globally
or a common shared,
understanding or
vocabulary for that.
And it contains a proof that
allows me to verify
the identity
and that this has never been
tampered with. So this,
university degrees is a pretty
simple but obvious use case,
but this concept
is very powerful.
I'll dive into what a proof
looks like because
we haven't,
sort of isolated here.
What a proof has
is it's flexible.
You can use all
kinds of different
mechanisms. This is using,
ECDSA elliptical curve
digital signing,
you know, your typical public
private key pair,
and providing
a verification and
information that would allow
anyone receiving this to
independently verify that this
credential is
valid and that it
was in fact issued by,
who said they issued it.
And there's a couple
ways of doing this.
JWT, which stands for JSON Web
Tokens for those
not familiar,
is one way.
there's LD proofs as
another common way.
LD proofs, one of
the advantages
it has is it allows this data
to be signed by
multiple parties.
So we call that
multiple signature.
But if, say, three
people needed
to sign a piece
of data for you
to consider it valid,
you can actually
embed the identity
of those three
people signing it.
The other thing you can start
doing is you can encapsulate
credentials. So I could take
this credential,
wrap another
credential around it,
and there's a lot of other
powerful things.
What problem does
this end up solving?
It ends up solving this trust
problem in that you
have the ability
to now have data
submitted to you.
It no longer matters
how it came to you.
Prior to this, we built custom
security mechanisms
into a single
application, which
has to control
everything. Again,
that model falls
down very quickly
when you have
multiple ways that
data can get updated
from multiple
sources. So we need a way to
understand if we
can trust the data
and authenticate
the data without
having necessarily a single
gateway into our system.
So I'll start talking through
some specifics on
how we implement
some of this trust
and time travel,
and create data
centric security
around semantic graph data.
And there's some things we'll
get into around
here very quickly
around how we can
extend semantic data,
or extend triples to
be able to do this.
but at a high level,
this is how we view the stack
that needs to do this.
So the core is trust.
It's the idea that
any data that
is in the system,
you can prove
the origins of how
that data got there.
And you can represent that to
anyone who needs that,
including a machine
or an algorithm
that might be
making decisions.
They have the ability to
independently verify that this
data has integrity.
Of course, semantics,
which I think probably most
people here are
familiar with,
so it provides a great way of
connecting data
together through
linked data, in this other set
of standards.
We need to create
business rules
around security,
and we do this
in a way we call
smart functions.
You know, I mentioned before
shackle is a way
of doing this,
but more specifically around,
shapes of data.
So there'll probably
be multiple
mechanisms of
wrapping the security
around who can modify,
who can do what
with the system.
We need time. Again,
if we're collaborating around
data across multiple parties,
we're never gonna get anywhere
unless we can
agree on a common
view of the world.
And current databases,
which destroy data
with every update,
will never be able to give us
that common view.
So we need to be able to lock
in time and know
that a version
of data will never
ever change.
Again, much like
source control,
where we can go
back and actually
get to previous states of
information and
issue additional
queries or find
different things
at that moments in time.
And we need, you know,
open ways of sharing.
And that's what
this whole stack
ultimately allows you to do,
is that instead of
building custom APIs,
which are very
limited, expensive,
and have all the issues,
we can now open up the data
repositories to very rich
interfaces that
people know they
don't have to
custom code to it,
like SPARQL, like
SQL, like GraphQL,
different ways that they can
describe the data they want,
how they want it,
but are able to prove
the integrity,
we're able to
restrict the data
they can see, but still give
them the flexibility.
So, one of the big things we
talked about is how do we,
not only prove
the origin of data,
but prove data and
that it hasn't
changed over time
while representing
this common view
of the world.
And RDF, which
sits at the bottom
of all of this,
was not designed to do this,
but it's very simple to extend
to enable this type
of capability.
So I'll talk about how
we approached it,
and I'm sure there's probably
other ways to approach
this as well.
So, this is the, I think,
out of the box example
of RDF from W3C.
Here's a set of triples.
These triples represent this
simple graph that we're taking
a look at. the first thing we
need to do is we need to layer
time on it.
And the way we layer time in
computing is we build a log.
We build an event stream of
changes over time,
An append only
log that we don't
necessarily have
the ability to
manipulate the prior
pieces of data.
Now we do allow this because
sometimes regulation or other
issues come up.
But by default,
the data is never
physically destroyed.
So in this
particular example,
you know, Bob is
a friend of Alice,
but what if, Bob and Alice are
no longer friends and now Bob
is a friend of Jane?
Well, when we update
those triples,
what we want to do is we want
to append this
new information,
but effectively we want it to
look like this.
We want to strike out that Bob
is a friend of
Alice and we want
to add the triple that now Bob
is a friend of Jane.
so if we played
this log forward,
what we end up with is a new
view of time, where Bob is now
a friend of Jane,
and I don't see this triple.
So every moment in time just
creates triples,
But when we bring
it up to the log
format, which
understands time,
we have to extend
the triples.
So I think that's important is
what we're actually
creating is
different versions,
of the same database,
but every version
version itself
is its own database.
So how we extend this
is quite simple.
We add a true false boolean.
True means this is
data we're adding.
False means this is data that
used to be true, but
is no longer true.
So in this case,
how we represent
this as a triple
is we now have a four tuple,
four pieces of information.
And we're just saying
here that false,
this is a fact that used to be
true as of this
moment in time,
it's now false.
And as of this
moment in time,
it's now true. This
creates a transaction
, so all this happens
at the identical
moment in time and represents
a new database,
which we see at the bottom.
So the other thing
that we also
need to do is think about,
we talked about origins and
proving data. How do we know
that data hasn't
been tampered with?
How do we know that
it has integrity?
And in order to do that,
we can simply extend the RDF
model with one
additional piece
of information,
which is we tag every triple
with the transaction that
generated that triple.
And it sits in the log with
the triple itself
so that every
triple has
traceability back to
the transaction that did it.
And what we do is we actually
take that
transaction reference
and that can and
should just be
represented as more triples.
I should be able to
query that data.
I should be able
to add a bunch
of metadata around
that transaction,
how it got into the system.
So when we look back at that
verifiable credential,
which has things like proofs
embedded in it,
all that can sit
as transactional
metadata. So now
when I get a triple
as a result of a query,
I can trace it back
to the transaction,
And then I can basically query
for that transaction,
which is just more triples and
get all the metadata
about it,
including the proofs
that originated it,
including perhaps the machine
or whatever else
I wanna store.
Importantly, we store
a wall clock time,
and this is
convenient to allow
you to query the data at any
historical moment in time,
instead of having
to query the data
as of time one, time
two, time three.
We can now say we wanna query
the database as of
the first of May.
And what we're able to do is
look up the triple of what
transaction ID were we at at
the first of May.
And then that is
the version of
the data that we want to issue
a query against.
We can also hash
the results of
every one of these
transactions.
So what the hashes allow us to
do now is to prove
every transaction
that it has never
been tampered with,
even though we do not have to
disclose all the data
in the database.
So if anyone ever demands or
needed to know or
machine needed
to know that data had not been
manipulated, it
becomes actually
quite trivial to be able to
provide that information.
And how we do that,
and just because
we're starting
to run out of time,
I won't get into
it in detail.
But, this,
we use the concept
of Merkle roots.
And what Merkle
roots allow you
to do is basically hash data.
So every one of
these, a, b, c,
d, all the way up to p here,
you can think of
as an individual
transaction. And
all we need to
do is represent this tree that
ultimately represents a single
hash value at the tip
of the tree.
So as long as I publish or
disclose this hash value,
which in no way discloses any
of the data within
the system,
If I ever need to
prove the transaction
integrity, for example,
around the triples
within, you know,
transaction k here,
all I need is a couple other
hash values to be
able to do that.
So I can actually prove,
any piece of
information within
the system without actually
having to disclose
all the data
in the system.
So the last piece
of the puzzle
is how do we control
the business logic?
So what our goal
here is is not
only to have
business logic that
guarantees the shape of data,
like if we add a customer,
that customer must
have an address,
for example. And
that's something
that like a shackle can,
help us accomplish.
But also who can
update customers?
Perhaps customers can update
their own records.
I mean, that's one of the cool
things about getting to this
model is we actually bring our
data repositories.
Instead of behind
layers of firewalls,
we bring them out
where people,
if they have permission,
can independently update their
own data and even
own their own data,
even though we're controlling
the repository.
And the quick
answer to this is
we use a concept called
smart functions.
What it is is it's a virtual
machine directly in the data
layer that you can
write a series
of rules.
What makes it so powerful is
that those rules can actually
leverage the current state of
the data or the current graph
to answer those.
So perhaps I can
see an employee
salary if I'm the employee,
or I'm the manager,
or the manager's manager all
the way up to the CEO,
or anyone who has
a relationship
called HR
responsibility for me.
That's a simple
rule that can be,
described embedded in
a smart function.
And dynamically, when
someone queries,
you know, select
star from from
salary for the employee base,
those rules are triggered,
and the data I do not have
permission to see is dropped.
It effectively
doesn't exist in
my version of the database.
And this is what
allows us to,
without having to build APIs,
open up these nice,
rich interfaces for
individuals to use.
so I have a couple examples of
sort of using
those relationships
and filtering out data.
the great thing is you can get
as crazy as you want.
You know, here's a rule that
says you can only
see friends,
using, you know,
probably a silly example,
but you can only
see friends if
those friends like
art by Leonardo
da Vinci. And all you have to
do is represent the the crawl
of the graph in
a smart function
that has to be valid.
And if it is valid,
that data,
that triple exists for you.
If it's not valid,
that triple just
simply doesn't
exist for you.
You'll never see it.
And these same rules can be
expressed not only for
read permissions,
but also write permissions.
Who is the ability to update
data and under
what conditions?
And ultimately,
by putting this,
I have a central
source of truth
at the data layer.
I can open up, instead of in
multiple applications
or multiple APIs,
I can open up richer access to
the data and and actually have
my data now truly participate
in a data web or
linked data web.
And I create so
much more value
and usability out of the data
because our only way of doing
this sort of thing today is to
build custom APIs and not only
put the effort
into code them,
but put the effort
into hopefully
maintain them
properly over time.
And, as I mentioned before,
that imposes a cost
not only on you,
but on every consumer of your
data as well.
So it gets us
completely out of
that cycle. So that's it.
I, I know I'm out
of time here.
I would love to be
able to, take,
questions in the time
we have remaining.
Hey. thank you
very much, Brian.
this was a great
presentation.
we do have a couple
questions.
and, the first one
is from Phil.
Phil is asking if,
your technology task,
stack, sorry, flurry,
is it a good model to solve
tenancy and cross
tenancy access,
versus graph partitioning,
for example?
Yeah. absolutely. It is.
And, you know, it's
also an effective
solution for segmenting,
different types
of data as well.
For example, you may store,
PII data in
a different repository
than you store,
data about the individual,
but without identifying
information.
The reason you
might do that is
you might want to be able to
offer proof these
proofs around
the data integrity
without linking
it directly to PII data.
You know, SPARQL
gives us great
ways of combining data across
repositories,
federated queries,
and, yeah, we can
piece together
data with different
characteristics.
We can piece
together data across
multiple organizations.
And by having the data
defend itself,
having the security in there,
we can really just
more liberally
open up the data
to those people
who need it that
right now have
a hard time getting
their hands on.
Great. thank you.
Emilio, Stani is asking if you
keep an eye on
Solid technology
as a decentralized
mechanism. Yeah.
so, yeah, we love
what Solid is doing.
I think they're, you know,
from a vision standpoint,
I think we're
really well aligned
with them. so absolutely.
our focus has always
been a little
bit more on cryptography and
embedding business logic and
things like time travel for
enabling people
in machines that
truly need to leverage data in
sort of a critical manner.
So, but absolutely, you know,
I think we have
similar visions
for the world. Great.
One, one more question.
So, like,
the the time travel,
the, the the the information,
the four triple,
I I see there's,
like, added complexity
over, like,
I would say, a standard basic
triple store. how is that
influencing the scalability,
and the the query
performance,
time, of your database?
And, would you
maybe give, like,
some, you know,
applications around
that and, yeah.
Yeah. So,
there is additional
complexity.
I think we do a really
good job of,
not bothering you
with it unless
you care about it.
So, you know,
if if you don't need to embed
the data security
at the data layer,
you wanna do it
like a traditional
app server, you can.
And you don't
have to learn any
of that if that's
not something
you're planning
on doing today.
A lot of
the cryptography happens
behind the scenes.
We have ways that
allow you to,
you know, basically set up,
what we call authorities that
allow an entity,
perhaps your app,
to transact on behalf of other
individuals within
their, a system.
So we try and do
a lot of things
where you really
don't need to
think about these
things unless you need them or
until you're ready
to use them.
as far as query performance,
I'm I'm glad you
asked about it.
One thing that is very,
very different
about how Flurry,
established itself
is it's a very
cloud friendly architecture.
And the query side is actually
completely independent from
the ledger side,
the update side.
Every database you've probably
ever used has a single machine
that always does both of those
functions.
By separating those,
we now completely
decouple the scalability
of those two functions.
So as weird as it sounds,
the query database engine is
actually a stateless
database,
which is kinda crazy because
the whole reason
you use a database
is to maintain state.
it's stateless in that it can
sit in a container,
it runs in memory.
The way we handle
immutable data,
we don't change data,
means that everything becomes
very cacheable upstream.
So, all of these nodes,
you can scale
from one query to
a thousand query nodes,
scale them back down again,
linear scalability.
We even have
the entire database
engine in JavaScript,
and it can run-in
a web browser
inside of a web app.
So, there's immense
flexibility.
And in many cases, in fact,
a lot of cases,
actually a huge boost in query
performance and
speed over other
database, engines.
Hi, everyone.
welcome, to, this next talk.
and we, are glad
to have here,
now, Brian Platz,
and Brian is
the CEO of Flurry.
So, Brian,
you're going to discuss data
centric security,
which is a very
interesting topic.
And, here is, the mic.
we're ready for
your presentation.
Great. Thank you.
and it's great to be here.
So thanks for attending and
participating. Yeah.
We're gonna dive in,
pretty quickly,
but I'd say at a pretty deep
level as to what data center
security and, in particular,
in a semantic graph model,
would look like.
In fact, what we
will do let me
make sure I can
advance my slides.
Here we go.
we'll first sort
of define what
we mean by data
centric security.
We'll talk about, why
this is important.
So the what and
the why and then how.
and of course, we'll
use Flurry since,
it's one I'm
familiar with, but,
Flurry is
a implementation model
of enforcing that data
centric security.
so first with
the, what is it?
What are we talking about?
So this is a term
I really enjoy,
this, data defending itself.
And ultimately,
we think that this is what we
are gonna need
around a significant
part of data management
as a whole,
especially as we
start to connect
data more and more,
connect it,
not only within our four walls
of our organization,
but outside our four walls.
And so data
defending us itself
means at least three things in
our vernacular.
One is knowing that you can
trust the data.
And, you know,
as we see more and much more
machine to machine interaction
around data, effectively,
the machines need, you know,
the same thing
us humans need.
when we're browsing the web,
we get the little lock icon
letting us know that the data
is secure and can be trusted
from where it came from.
that concept hasn't
really existed
or needed to be pushed forward
in the data world
because we've
never really had a truly
interconnected
data ecosystem.
But I think we can draw a lot
of parallels to the world wide
web that we as humans need and
the tools we need around them
to the data web
that ultimately
is where we're going.
So, cryptography, obviously,
and and we'll talk
about, you know,
how that can be accomplished.
But, AI, you know,
machine learning,
machines that are
consuming this
data directly
need to know that
the data they're
they're making
decisions around,
can be trusted.
secondly, that
you can reproduce
the data.
So especially if
we, arrive in a,
what I would say a multiple
observer world where multiple
parties are interacting with,
a single set of data,
trying to coordinate
or collaborate
around a single
source of truth.
They can't do
that in a typical
database model.
A typical database model is
extraordinary historically,
it was designed this
way for reasons,
but it's extraordinarily good
at destroying data.
So, when you update a piece of
information,
you're effectively
throwing out the old
information.
It might exist in
a log for some
period of time,
but the old data is gone.
If we're having
multiple parties
coordinating and
making decisions
around data,
the first thing we
really need is a common frame
of reference. I often draw
parallels to this
with software
source control.
It was
extraordinarily difficult
before we had things like Git
source control for multiple
developers to build code,
because there was no common
frame of reference.
They're constantly stomping on
top of each other.
There was no central
truth to the world,
no reproducible truth.
Data needs that
identical model,
especially when
we're collaborating
around data, again,
not only internally,
but possibly externally,
creating these data ecosystems
with other parties.
So the reproducibility of data
is gonna become very,
very critical.
And, you know, the thing that
we reference here is this idea
of time travel.
Being able to issue a query,
not only for the current
state of data,
but every historical moment of
data that existed.
And again, sitting
on that first
foundation,
knowing that we can
trust the data that
we're getting,
that it hasn't been
tampered with.
And lastly,
data defending
itself means that
it is impossible to circumvent
the security that's
been defined,
the business rules,
whatever they are,
around who can update data and
what the shape
of data needs to
look like. So, you know,
when we think
about, semantic,
standards, we
think about things
like OWL or Shackle
giving some
degree of definition
around how
data needs to look
for it to be valid.
So we need to be able to take
this a bit further,
and we need to
be able to layer
permissioning on top of it.
So not just data shape
is being valid,
but who can change data,
and importantly,
who can see data.
So this would be
the last layer
of what we mean
by data centric
security. So why, why
is this important?
And what we see
is for businesses
to really be competitive,
they are gonna
have to be agile
and get value out of
the data they have.
I mean, I think, you know,
a lot of organizations today
wouldn't necessarily,
consider themselves
data poor,
but they'd probably consider
themselves insights poor or
knowledge poor.
So they have a lot of data.
It's just sitting there.
It's locked away.
It's very difficult
to leverage.
And that's really a symptom of
how we have been building
applications for
the last forty years.
So we have been
developing things
in a very application
centric model,
where the data we
have is really
subservient to
the application.
And as we've needed to expose
that data in other ways,
we develop what I
consider workarounds.
I consider these flaws of our
current data model,
which are APIs.
I don't think APIs should need
to exist to get
access to data.
but what they are is a very
narrow pipe into
that data that's
defined and then imposes costs
not only on the individuals
having to develop the APIs,
perhaps your own
organization,
but it imposes a huge cost on
the consumers of that data.
Because now all they all have
to write custom code
to your custom API,
and then importantly maintain
that over time.
And oftentimes,
it's the maintenance of these
APIs that also
get us in trouble
that introduce
security breaches.
Or we have the other
workaround,
which is I need
to aggregate or
look at this data
across repositories.
I have no good way
of doing that,
so I turn to data
lights or data
warehouses. So I think most of
the people here are probably
familiar with and
fans of semantic
web sort of technology.
But what it allows us to do is
it gives us a foundation
to move into,
instead of an application
centric world,
into a data centric world.
But this then brings this
additional set of
problems around
trust of data, guaranteeing
integrity of data.
Because what it means is that
instead of just
a single observer,
single pipe into these data
repositories
where everything's
controlled, now we
have an ecosystem
of applications,
which gives us
tremendous leverage.
It gives us a lot
of flexibility
around data.
but it also means that our
previous methods of trying to
secure data in the application
tier start to fall
apart because
there is no such
thing as a single
application with
being the only
thing that has access
to data anymore.
It's multiple applications,
but the data is more reusable
and can be leveraged.
So we need to start
thinking about,
embedding security
into the data
tier to make this
world possible
and start connecting
these data sources.
So that's why we think this is
important. So I'll tackle some
of the things we talked about
with some examples of some,
technologies that address some
of these concerns.
So the first thing
that I mentioned,
we think data centric security
means is that you have to be
able to trust the data.
You have to know that the data
has integrity, and this has to
be done in a way
that a machine
can even trust
the integrity of data.
There's really
exciting standard
here that is,
emerging W3C standard around
verifiable credentials.
I'm gonna extend
how you typically
see it, but I'm gonna
use the typical
use cases here for those not
familiar with it
and and how it
works and how it
guarantees data
integrity. In fact,
one of the things
we talk about
these credentials is that it's
like data containers.
We we talk a lot about, like,
Docker and and
computing containers
now a day, currently
in our IT world.
And we think that,
these same principles
can apply to data.
And verifiable credentials is
really the the preeminent,
standard that's
coming around this.
So verifiable credentials is
under the W3C,
the same, you know,
standards body
holding the other
semantic web, standards.
And it's actually
based on even
though a lot of people who are
using it don't
necessarily know
it's based on semantic
web technologies,
it's sitting
entirely on top of
semantic web technologies.
So what is
a verifiable credential
and what does it
matter to data
centric security?
How is this going
to solve some
of these problems that we've
talked about?
the classic example in an area
where we're spending a lot of
time on because there's a lot
of momentum is
the university system.
anything that is a important
piece of information
is what you
would call a credential.
We have a lot of physical
credentials today that would
include your
driver's license,
your passport,
and as it relates
to a university,
it would be your degree.
But of course,
it's very difficult
to validate some of
these mechanisms.
And of course,
they're not digital,
they're mostly physical,
because they're
very important.
So verifiable credentials is
designed to do this.
What it allows,
to happen is that
an issuer can
create a digital, credential.
In this case, it's
a university example.
We're creating
a digital degree,
for out of a university.
And a holder, in this
case the student,
gets that degree.
So blockchain often comes into
this conversation.
Flurry spends a lot
of time, in fact,
its ledger is based
on blockchain
technology, but
it isn't actually
required to make
all this work.
So there's some
optionality to it.
But the benefit
of a credential
is that the data does not need
to be published in a public
manner at all. So,
privacy around
the data is always,
integral to this.
And in fact, in
the coming years,
there's already
examples coming out.
I'm sure Android,
I'm sure iOS will probably be
shipping out of
the box with a out
of the box,
application for holding your
credentials in a wallet.
So in iOS, iPhone,
you already have a wallet for
your credit cards,
you will have
a wallet for these
credentials, which will hold
things like your
driver's license,
and they'll hold things like
your university degrees,
and potentially lots
of other things.
And one of the benefits
is, as a holder,
you determine who you disclose
the data to.
But whoever you
disclose it to,
in this particular example,
would be an employer
that you're
trying to prove you
have this degree,
can independently verify that
that data has integrity,
that it was in fact issued by
the university,
that it's never been
tampered with.
And they can prove
that without
having to use
something like a third
party background
check provider
in order to validate
information.
It can be directly proven.
So this starts to get into how
we prove identity.
And if we, you know,
just step back real quick to
this world where
we have a these
these data pods that are
interconnected and
multiple parties,
multiple applications might be
transacting data,
identity becomes critical.
Because how do we know we can
trust this person?
We no longer have
a single pathway
into updating data,
which is
the application sitting
in front of it.
There's multiple
pathways to do it.
So, a very complimentary,
but independent standard is
around decentralized
identifiers.
And these often goes
hand in hand with,
verifiable credentials.
Decentralized
identifiers allow
you to register
identities, typically,
public, private,
or asymmetric,
cryptography.
So you can release
a public key
but keep a private
key that you
never disclose.
So it's a much safer mechanism
for securing information or
proving identity than
say a password,
which is what we mostly use.
these identities do need to be
registered somewhere
where both parties,
the verifier and the issuer,
can jointly look them up.
And a blockchain
is a very logical
place to put these,
although they don't have to go
on a blockchain.
I could email it to you.
I could put it up on
our public website.
there's multiple ways of
representing them,
which is inherently
what makes them,
decentralized and referred to
as decentralized identifiers.
So you're starting
to see these
a lot more. You're
gonna see them,
much more frequently,
these strings here
that start with DID,
which stands for decentralized
identifier. So what you do is
you take this
credential and you
wrap it in a digital
signature.
That digital signature allows
the employer to
verify that that
is impossible for anyone else
to have issued
this information
except for the identifier
of the issuer.
So that's the basics
of verifiable
credentials, and that's kinda
how they work. What
do they look like?
so if anyone here is familiar
with JSON LD, which is really
just a way of
representing triples,
representing RDF data,
JSON LD is the main mechanism
to represent a credential.
And what we're able to do,
and this would be a sample
credential for
a bachelor degree,
we're able to
provide a context.
This is effectively,
you know,
in a sparkle world,
like a prefix,
except it's a set of prefixes
that are predefined,
and a payload of data.
And this is a data container.
It is self describing data in
a containerized
package that can
also contain a proof
that enables
us to validate that
this data is valid,
that it's never been
tampered with.
So, if we looked
at, for example,
what this context points to,
this context is, you know,
setting up basically
what you're
probably used to seeing is
prefixes for URIs and bringing
definition to all
the data in here.
So if I wanted to
know what a bachelor
degree, you know,
this degree is of type
bachelor degree.
Well, that may mean a lot of
different things to a lot of
different people.
I can refer to
the context here,
you know, look up,
bachelor degree,
which I don't see
it right now,
but I'm sure it's
in here somewhere.
You all probably see it.
Here's bachelor degree.
And I can see that,
bachelor degree refers to this
formal definition
of, you know,
example dot com slash
bachelor degree.
But you see in here,
some of these definitions are
referring to schema
dot org, etcetera.
So we have now global shared
schemas that I
can containerize
this data. I can share it with
other people. They
have the ability
to then reference,
for example,
schema dot org and understand
what all these terms are that
I put in here with a globally
or a common shared,
understanding or
vocabulary for that.
And it contains a proof that
allows me to verify
the identity
and that this has never been
tampered with. So this,
university degrees is a pretty
simple but obvious use case,
but this concept
is very powerful.
I'll dive into what a proof
looks like because
we haven't,
sort of isolated here.
What a proof has
is it's flexible.
You can use all
kinds of different
mechanisms. This is using,
ECDSA elliptical curve
digital signing,
you know, your typical public
private key pair,
and providing
a verification and
information that would allow
anyone receiving this to
independently verify that this
credential is
valid and that it
was in fact issued by,
who said they issued it.
And there's a couple
ways of doing this.
JWT, which stands for JSON Web
Tokens for those
not familiar,
is one way.
there's LD proofs as
another common way.
LD proofs, one of
the advantages
it has is it allows this data
to be signed by
multiple parties.
So we call that
multiple signature.
But if, say, three
people needed
to sign a piece
of data for you
to consider it valid,
you can actually
embed the identity
of those three
people signing it.
The other thing you can start
doing is you can encapsulate
credentials. So I could take
this credential,
wrap another
credential around it,
and there's a lot of other
powerful things.
What problem does
this end up solving?
It ends up solving this trust
problem in that you
have the ability
to now have data
submitted to you.
It no longer matters
how it came to you.
Prior to this, we built custom
security mechanisms
into a single
application, which
has to control
everything. Again,
that model falls
down very quickly
when you have
multiple ways that
data can get updated
from multiple
sources. So we need a way to
understand if we
can trust the data
and authenticate
the data without
having necessarily a single
gateway into our system.
So I'll start talking through
some specifics on
how we implement
some of this trust
and time travel,
and create data
centric security
around semantic graph data.
And there's some things we'll
get into around
here very quickly
around how we can
extend semantic data,
or extend triples to
be able to do this.
but at a high level,
this is how we view the stack
that needs to do this.
So the core is trust.
It's the idea that
any data that
is in the system,
you can prove
the origins of how
that data got there.
And you can represent that to
anyone who needs that,
including a machine
or an algorithm
that might be
making decisions.
They have the ability to
independently verify that this
data has integrity.
Of course, semantics,
which I think probably most
people here are
familiar with,
so it provides a great way of
connecting data
together through
linked data, in this other set
of standards.
We need to create
business rules
around security,
and we do this
in a way we call
smart functions.
You know, I mentioned before
shackle is a way
of doing this,
but more specifically around,
shapes of data.
So there'll probably
be multiple
mechanisms of
wrapping the security
around who can modify,
who can do what
with the system.
We need time. Again,
if we're collaborating around
data across multiple parties,
we're never gonna get anywhere
unless we can
agree on a common
view of the world.
And current databases,
which destroy data
with every update,
will never be able to give us
that common view.
So we need to be able to lock
in time and know
that a version
of data will never
ever change.
Again, much like
source control,
where we can go
back and actually
get to previous states of
information and
issue additional
queries or find
different things
at that moments in time.
And we need, you know,
open ways of sharing.
And that's what
this whole stack
ultimately allows you to do,
is that instead of
building custom APIs,
which are very
limited, expensive,
and have all the issues,
we can now open up the data
repositories to very rich
interfaces that
people know they
don't have to
custom code to it,
like SPARQL, like
SQL, like GraphQL,
different ways that they can
describe the data they want,
how they want it,
but are able to prove
the integrity,
we're able to
restrict the data
they can see, but still give
them the flexibility.
So, one of the big things we
talked about is how do we,
not only prove
the origin of data,
but prove data and
that it hasn't
changed over time
while representing
this common view
of the world.
And RDF, which
sits at the bottom
of all of this,
was not designed to do this,
but it's very simple to extend
to enable this type
of capability.
So I'll talk about how
we approached it,
and I'm sure there's probably
other ways to approach
this as well.
So, this is the, I think,
out of the box example
of RDF from W3C.
Here's a set of triples.
These triples represent this
simple graph that we're taking
a look at. the first thing we
need to do is we need to layer
time on it.
And the way we layer time in
computing is we build a log.
We build an event stream of
changes over time,
An append only
log that we don't
necessarily have
the ability to
manipulate the prior
pieces of data.
Now we do allow this because
sometimes regulation or other
issues come up.
But by default,
the data is never
physically destroyed.
So in this
particular example,
you know, Bob is
a friend of Alice,
but what if, Bob and Alice are
no longer friends and now Bob
is a friend of Jane?
Well, when we update
those triples,
what we want to do is we want
to append this
new information,
but effectively we want it to
look like this.
We want to strike out that Bob
is a friend of
Alice and we want
to add the triple that now Bob
is a friend of Jane.
so if we played
this log forward,
what we end up with is a new
view of time, where Bob is now
a friend of Jane,
and I don't see this triple.
So every moment in time just
creates triples,
But when we bring
it up to the log
format, which
understands time,
we have to extend
the triples.
So I think that's important is
what we're actually
creating is
different versions,
of the same database,
but every version
version itself
is its own database.
So how we extend this
is quite simple.
We add a true false boolean.
True means this is
data we're adding.
False means this is data that
used to be true, but
is no longer true.
So in this case,
how we represent
this as a triple
is we now have a four tuple,
four pieces of information.
And we're just saying
here that false,
this is a fact that used to be
true as of this
moment in time,
it's now false.
And as of this
moment in time,
it's now true. This
creates a transaction
, so all this happens
at the identical
moment in time and represents
a new database,
which we see at the bottom.
So the other thing
that we also
need to do is think about,
we talked about origins and
proving data. How do we know
that data hasn't
been tampered with?
How do we know that
it has integrity?
And in order to do that,
we can simply extend the RDF
model with one
additional piece
of information,
which is we tag every triple
with the transaction that
generated that triple.
And it sits in the log with
the triple itself
so that every
triple has
traceability back to
the transaction that did it.
And what we do is we actually
take that
transaction reference
and that can and
should just be
represented as more triples.
I should be able to
query that data.
I should be able
to add a bunch
of metadata around
that transaction,
how it got into the system.
So when we look back at that
verifiable credential,
which has things like proofs
embedded in it,
all that can sit
as transactional
metadata. So now
when I get a triple
as a result of a query,
I can trace it back
to the transaction,
And then I can basically query
for that transaction,
which is just more triples and
get all the metadata
about it,
including the proofs
that originated it,
including perhaps the machine
or whatever else
I wanna store.
Importantly, we store
a wall clock time,
and this is
convenient to allow
you to query the data at any
historical moment in time,
instead of having
to query the data
as of time one, time
two, time three.
We can now say we wanna query
the database as of
the first of May.
And what we're able to do is
look up the triple of what
transaction ID were we at at
the first of May.
And then that is
the version of
the data that we want to issue
a query against.
We can also hash
the results of
every one of these
transactions.
So what the hashes allow us to
do now is to prove
every transaction
that it has never
been tampered with,
even though we do not have to
disclose all the data
in the database.
So if anyone ever demands or
needed to know or
machine needed
to know that data had not been
manipulated, it
becomes actually
quite trivial to be able to
provide that information.
And how we do that,
and just because
we're starting
to run out of time,
I won't get into
it in detail.
But, this,
we use the concept
of Merkle roots.
And what Merkle
roots allow you
to do is basically hash data.
So every one of
these, a, b, c,
d, all the way up to p here,
you can think of
as an individual
transaction. And
all we need to
do is represent this tree that
ultimately represents a single
hash value at the tip
of the tree.
So as long as I publish or
disclose this hash value,
which in no way discloses any
of the data within
the system,
If I ever need to
prove the transaction
integrity, for example,
around the triples
within, you know,
transaction k here,
all I need is a couple other
hash values to be
able to do that.
So I can actually prove,
any piece of
information within
the system without actually
having to disclose
all the data
in the system.
So the last piece
of the puzzle
is how do we control
the business logic?
So what our goal
here is is not
only to have
business logic that
guarantees the shape of data,
like if we add a customer,
that customer must
have an address,
for example. And
that's something
that like a shackle can,
help us accomplish.
But also who can
update customers?
Perhaps customers can update
their own records.
I mean, that's one of the cool
things about getting to this
model is we actually bring our
data repositories.
Instead of behind
layers of firewalls,
we bring them out
where people,
if they have permission,
can independently update their
own data and even
own their own data,
even though we're controlling
the repository.
And the quick
answer to this is
we use a concept called
smart functions.
What it is is it's a virtual
machine directly in the data
layer that you can
write a series
of rules.
What makes it so powerful is
that those rules can actually
leverage the current state of
the data or the current graph
to answer those.
So perhaps I can
see an employee
salary if I'm the employee,
or I'm the manager,
or the manager's manager all
the way up to the CEO,
or anyone who has
a relationship
called HR
responsibility for me.
That's a simple
rule that can be,
described embedded in
a smart function.
And dynamically, when
someone queries,
you know, select
star from from
salary for the employee base,
those rules are triggered,
and the data I do not have
permission to see is dropped.
It effectively
doesn't exist in
my version of the database.
And this is what
allows us to,
without having to build APIs,
open up these nice,
rich interfaces for
individuals to use.
so I have a couple examples of
sort of using
those relationships
and filtering out data.
the great thing is you can get
as crazy as you want.
You know, here's a rule that
says you can only
see friends,
using, you know,
probably a silly example,
but you can only
see friends if
those friends like
art by Leonardo
da Vinci. And all you have to
do is represent the the crawl
of the graph in
a smart function
that has to be valid.
And if it is valid,
that data,
that triple exists for you.
If it's not valid,
that triple just
simply doesn't
exist for you.
You'll never see it.
And these same rules can be
expressed not only for
read permissions,
but also write permissions.
Who is the ability to update
data and under
what conditions?
And ultimately,
by putting this,
I have a central
source of truth
at the data layer.
I can open up, instead of in
multiple applications
or multiple APIs,
I can open up richer access to
the data and and actually have
my data now truly participate
in a data web or
linked data web.
And I create so
much more value
and usability out of the data
because our only way of doing
this sort of thing today is to
build custom APIs and not only
put the effort
into code them,
but put the effort
into hopefully
maintain them
properly over time.
And, as I mentioned before,
that imposes a cost
not only on you,
but on every consumer of your
data as well.
So it gets us
completely out of
that cycle. So that's it.
I, I know I'm out
of time here.
I would love to be
able to, take,
questions in the time
we have remaining.
Hey. thank you
very much, Brian.
this was a great
presentation.
we do have a couple
questions.
and, the first one
is from Phil.
Phil is asking if,
your technology task,
stack, sorry, flurry,
is it a good model to solve
tenancy and cross
tenancy access,
versus graph partitioning,
for example?
Yeah. absolutely. It is.
And, you know, it's
also an effective
solution for segmenting,
different types
of data as well.
For example, you may store,
PII data in
a different repository
than you store,
data about the individual,
but without identifying
information.
The reason you
might do that is
you might want to be able to
offer proof these
proofs around
the data integrity
without linking
it directly to PII data.
You know, SPARQL
gives us great
ways of combining data across
repositories,
federated queries,
and, yeah, we can
piece together
data with different
characteristics.
We can piece
together data across
multiple organizations.
And by having the data
defend itself,
having the security in there,
we can really just
more liberally
open up the data
to those people
who need it that
right now have
a hard time getting
their hands on.
Great. thank you.
Emilio, Stani is asking if you
keep an eye on
Solid technology
as a decentralized
mechanism. Yeah.
so, yeah, we love
what Solid is doing.
I think they're, you know,
from a vision standpoint,
I think we're
really well aligned
with them. so absolutely.
our focus has always
been a little
bit more on cryptography and
embedding business logic and
things like time travel for
enabling people
in machines that
truly need to leverage data in
sort of a critical manner.
So, but absolutely, you know,
I think we have
similar visions
for the world. Great.
One, one more question.
So, like,
the the time travel,
the, the the the information,
the four triple,
I I see there's,
like, added complexity
over, like,
I would say, a standard basic
triple store. how is that
influencing the scalability,
and the the query
performance,
time, of your database?
And, would you
maybe give, like,
some, you know,
applications around
that and, yeah.
Yeah. So,
there is additional
complexity.
I think we do a really
good job of,
not bothering you
with it unless
you care about it.
So, you know,
if if you don't need to embed
the data security
at the data layer,
you wanna do it
like a traditional
app server, you can.
And you don't
have to learn any
of that if that's
not something
you're planning
on doing today.
A lot of
the cryptography happens
behind the scenes.
We have ways that
allow you to,
you know, basically set up,
what we call authorities that
allow an entity,
perhaps your app,
to transact on behalf of other
individuals within
their, a system.
So we try and do
a lot of things
where you really
don't need to
think about these
things unless you need them or
until you're ready
to use them.
as far as query performance,
I'm I'm glad you
asked about it.
One thing that is very,
very different
about how Flurry,
established itself
is it's a very
cloud friendly architecture.
And the query side is actually
completely independent from
the ledger side,
the update side.
Every database you've probably
ever used has a single machine
that always does both of those
functions.
By separating those,
we now completely
decouple the scalability
of those two functions.
So as weird as it sounds,
the query database engine is
actually a stateless
database,
which is kinda crazy because
the whole reason
you use a database
is to maintain state.
it's stateless in that it can
sit in a container,
it runs in memory.
The way we handle
immutable data,
we don't change data,
means that everything becomes
very cacheable upstream.
So, all of these nodes,
you can scale
from one query to
a thousand query nodes,
scale them back down again,
linear scalability.
We even have
the entire database
engine in JavaScript,
and it can run-in
a web browser
inside of a web app.
So, there's immense
flexibility.
And in many cases, in fact,
a lot of cases,
actually a huge boost in query
performance and
speed over other
database, engines. Great.
Thank you very much, Brian.
Thank you again
for your talk.
And, you know, looking forward
to to hear more.
you are, you have me,
your as a your sponsor
of the conference
. So I invite everyone to keep
the conversation going in,
for this booth.
Ask any question.
I'm sure, you guys
will be there,
to answer. So, thank you.
And, everyone, we are
now moving to the,
conference, closing party.
So, see you all,
there, in a minute.
Goodbye.
Thank you. Thank you,
Brian. Bye bye.